[Music]
sometimes when people approach me they
do so in such a familiar way that i
think i know them
because they do it in such a way that
like hey how's it hey justin uh how's it
going i saw um right they're familiar
with you so familiar somebody approached
me once with that energy in new york and
they said um
hey justin sorry
sorry to bother you but i i just have
this issue when i hit ctrl alt delete uh
on my mac i i can't seem to blah blah
blah it was some technical question
about their computer and i was so thrown
i was so confused and um
and i said i why
why are you i don't understand i don't i
don't really know anything about
computers and they're like aha very
funny but seriously when i do this when
i it's control out i can't seem to get
the thing and it was this technical
question about computers and they
i realized that they just assumed that i
knew about computers because i played
one in the uh apple p the mac piece you
know what's funny about that you know so
little about computers that you didn't
even know that control alt delete
is not a function that you perform on
macs oh really it's for pc okay well
then
you're listening to life short i'm your
computer illiterate host justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
ironically computer illiterate
that's brad humble right right no it's
not i don't know what's bragging i'm so
paranoid you're illiterate you are
somebody said i brag you are barely
literate though one of your computers oh
yeah i can turn it on you check your
email yes computers make me panic they
trigger me in a way that sorry i should
have introduced you um
i'm with my more computer literally more
but i don't know much
yeah they trigger me in a way like i
hate i i whenever i'm always afraid
something's gone wrong or
it's just technology in general but like
computer specifically is like i know so
little about and whenever i'm needing
help from somebody and they're walking
me through how to do something on a
computer there's always the point where
either they mention it or i do
which is and they're like relieved that
i have where i say you know this is
ironic that i don't know anything
because i did and for those of you uh
wondering what i'm alluding to
i did these commercials for apple apple
products for four years are you gonna
call them iconic no
no they were iconic though yeah
i can say it yeah i can't they were they
it was an iconic i understand that it
was commercial i still can't say run
what would you say campaign it was an
iconic it's weird i would say it's
in the top 10 most iconic commercial
campaigns of all time
i mean i i know maybe top five it's
funny i can step back and objectively
agree with you i i but it's i can't say
it out loud but i can say it they were
iconic commercials and it's also fair to
say that you
didn't get cast because of your
expertise
no in the computer world no in fact it
never came up in the um when we were
talking about doing them they never
asked uh i think maybe they asked if i
used the apple computers i maybe and i
think at the time i did i know i did um
but when i
i remember getting my first apple
computer which is before the campaigns
but um i didn't have one in college you
know i
i used to have to use computers and pc
too
well no until you started getting they
they would give you
some free stuff and then i'd give them
and i was the beneficiary of that as
well but in college i remember not
having a computer did you have one in
college i used to use the computer lab
oh really and my roommate's computer i
wonder why i got a computer yeah huh i
don't know
yeah well maybe
maybe they were maybe they were just
more convinced that i would use it
that's true yeah they knew that i was
like i wasn't long for college and like
why do you need a computer to do plays
that's kind of like what i was mostly
concentrating on so why are we talking
about these commercials
i'll tell you why
because your co-star
in them is our guest today oh yeah john
hodgman is um what a dear after we did
those of course we became very close
doing them and you're gonna hear you're
gonna hopefully our friendship will come
across uh he's just i i have to stop
saying this he's one of the best he well
he's one of the best he is right you
agree yeah you've known him for a long
time i don't say that without really
i guess sometimes i say it i don't say
willy nilly i'll say it willie
um but yeah i do say i think too often
but he is he so he played pc in these
iconic commercials he's also
um a great celebrated writer
very good actor very he's a humorous
he's a humorist he i was going back
looking for um
i have to you know when i post about it
on instagram i go and look for a good
old photo if it's somebody that i've
known
and i
the other day i was doing that for some
guests and i found so many there's so
many of me in hajj me like
you know because we'll get
when we go out uh we'll enjoy a drink or
two
and i get very touchy-feely with him i
have very like hands he seems fun to
touch he's
he's fun to type there's so i found so
many pictures of me like just all over
him like
kissing him and like up with my just
hugging um he is he's fun to touch yeah
i just i love doing those with him and
thank god because we spent so much time
together uh thank god he turned out to
be you know as great as he is as fun to
be around so uh hopefully yeah you guys
will enjoy
being around him in a way
and uh you'll get a little taste of what
i got to experience for four years doing
those commercials uh here it is my catch
up with my old pc pal
not politically correct yeah i know you
meant okay
yeah although he is very sensitive
uh and he is just a really special
wonderful human being i love him here he
is john hodgman
life could be a dream
[Music]
let's have a vow
let us
even though we are both in front of our
name-brand computers
let us have a vow to not search up
anything on the internet oh if we don't
know a thing
or can't remember the name of a
character in a movie or whatever i like
this we just have to not know is this
another part of the challenge this would
be more specific to us that we not
mention
the
product that shall not be named in this
sentence
uh can we see how long we can go without
mentioning it we're not going to mention
the name brand of the computers we're
okay
till till later in the show that's a
podcast technique called a tease
okay at the very end of the show
we'll count down from from three and
we'll both say what we remember
was the name of the company
okay we'll see if we are both remember
obviously we can't look it up no we
can't we just have to remember we just
have to use our memory boxes i was
reading uh
vacation
and i'm looking at your facial hair now
and i'm thinking about the stuff about
your you start the book off talking
about your facial hair it's so funny
right now you have because i remember
when i first saw i knew you so well as a
bare-faced person as a big baby
big brown baby
there was a there was a bunsen honeydew
element and there was yes and i always
thought of myself as having a beaker-ish
element so that i felt our charm and
whatever those
whatever we were doing together
yeah you know and you would kind of keep
an eye you're right you know don't you
think
is this just why didn't you bring up the
beaker thing before i thought i had i
just i don't know i assumed
i i feel like i would have remember i
feel like i would have remembered that i
remember those days very well very funny
yeah me too and we definitely had a lot
of buns i i definitely got some bunsen
honeydew cracks
and then you know after i turned uh
after i turned 40
i started experimenting with my facial
hair because
i moved into my 40s and i needed to
announce the world that i was
that i that i am actually sexually
repulsive and not deserve physical
affection anymore as you say you say in
the book it's really
it's really made me laugh um but you had
you had flirting vacation land by
vacation land uh it's fair through
stories from painful beaches it's so
good uh when do you do right when you're
um alone do you write when you're on
vacation
well what happened was this
we had a wonderful time working for a
name-brand computer
while i was also working for the daily
show with jon stewart
and that was a one-two unexpected
uh and very happy punch
that changed my life dramatically in the
year 2006.
and
then
by the by the mid
whatever 2010s
the the name brand computer company ads
ended
i've been writing a series of books full
of fake humorous
non-facts
that is what had gotten me the job on
the daily [ __ ] because on the daily show
i played this bunsen honey jewish
version of myself this know-it-ally
resident expert who was
out of his mind right the books i just
want to say is called the areas of my
expertise and there are two of them
right my first book of fake facts was
the areas of my expertise followed by
more information than you require
finally followed by
uh that is all right which came out in
2011 in the run-up to
the 2012 mayan calendar
conspiracy that the world was going to
end in 2012 we
they were off by eight years
yeah
god
the world didn't end in 2012 and by 2013
i was like oh i'm now in my early 40s
the work that i was doing for the
computer company is over this trilogy
or like i like to call it a trilogy
books
is ended i you know it was one of those
moments where you kind of take stock in
your life
and i had been performing on stage
material from the book for years
and i wanted to keep performing on stage
i decided mike biglia the the very the
very famous story
very funny and decent person
remember bigly was telling stories on
stage and in a in such a candid way and
i was like oh i like what he's doing and
i would love to
he had suggested that i do what he did
when he ran out and he still does when
he you know works through
his material and then is done with it is
to build up new material he would do a
residency at union hall in in park slope
brooklyn where i live
where i started doing a semi-secret show
called secret society just to give
myself a deadline for something to say
in front of an audience and initially it
started out very oddball and comedic and
phony
like what i had been doing before you
mean with a persona with a
a certain yeah i dress up as ein rand
and perform
as i ran
so she would enter she would enter my
body i would i would be for some reason
wearing a
a frumpy blue dress oh that wasn't
connected to the
yeah for iran
reason i would i would be wearing a 70s
here uh frumpy blue dress like the kind
ein rand used to wear when she would go
on phil donahue well incredible
incredible footage well they didn't see
that and then i would get up and and
talk about i talk as i ran for a while
and then i would take the ukulele and i
would sing as i ran wearing the money is
this all a joke this is all true this is
all true this is this was an act you can
look it up you can look uh
i can't oh i have to take your word for
it okay i'm not the goal wasn't so that
i could lie to you the goal
anyway okay to test her to test our
metal to test our brain
a battle of wits
yeah that well no just a fun a fr a
friend round yeah yeah a [ __ ] around a
friendly [ __ ] around i don't want to
battle my friends that was the thing
about the name brand computer
ads we were friends right even though i
was constantly undermining you and angry
and i was constantly telling you that i
was better than you in a passive
aggressive way i know and you really
hated doing that you were because we had
we were friends i know and the and the
characters were friends i mean it was it
was bernie
bernie and ert is it pretty hurt yes
bernie in earth well i'd look it up how
to bring the famous characters from
sesame street
i guess that was it you know and it's
that we had established such a natural
good friendship and funny enough our
dynamic was so really the opposite of uh
those characters certainly when it came
to technology you knew so much more
about technology and and that
you know yet to be named product that we
were selling than i did
and yet here i am the know-it-all who's
like uh who knows about this stuff he's
supposed to be telling you because
that's because you because i was the
nerd and you were just the embodiment of
cool
as far as and the name brand computer
that we were trying to i'm not sure you
understood the messaging that they were
no but i'm saying computer computer
computing
back then was associated with
businessmen and nerds yeah yeah and was
not
not integrated into everyday lifestyle
of young cool people
and that's what this name brand computer
company was trying to change and
successfully so successfully that um
they stopped doing the ads and then
right it's ironic the other thing that
happened of course a year after we
started the ads introduced a new product
which was a phone and the phone
has obviously changed our culture and
our society
dramatically
and it really effed up my fortunes
of being a lifelong name-brand computer
company
yeah
because the phone integrated itself into
everybody's life exactly the way
name brand computer company wanted to
have it and no one thought of it as a
computer they thought of it as
they thought of as a lifestyle tool
right and consequently the company
changed its emphasis on these other
things especially since their primary
competitor in the computer field had
kind of dropped out of it or
you're right john i mean think about it
they've become so integrated
to the point where we're now joking
about not using it about going maybe an
hour and a half two hours and not using
it you're saying it happened after
didn't the phone come out while we were
doing those uh yet to be named yeah yeah
yes and there was a time
i've been out there on twitter every day
since the last time we shot saying um
put me back in coach i'm ready to go
and i think we've it's well established
right if it's not we can establish it
again that we would love to keep doing
them we would love to do more but
or more or one or one
yeah anything yeah i still have the
glasses that i wore because these were
my frames i bought these
jeffrey dahmer-esque frames oh yeah look
at that you're john's putting them on
right now
in the other room i still have the vans
that uh they gave me you know those
slip-on ones oh yeah right
incredible team incredible fun so much
of it was because it was just this white
expanse it was this you know we were in
front of this void it was for the most
part um
technical setups like setting up the
game so it was just we would just stay
there so there's so much time in between
just shooting the [ __ ] and um yeah we'll
just hang out and talk and have fun and
yeah and you know for for a stretch of
time
right
between takes and they would set up
these big technical takes
and and rigs and stuff so there was a
lot of
down time surprisingly people might not
think that because it was so
simple i mean the concept isn't simple
but there were like technically that's
phil's doing phil morrison there was
there was a lot more uh involved
technically i think particularly the
first re the first round
phil and the team would shoot from
different angles
so there there would be
the thing we each have our own cameras
and then the wide camera of both of us
but then we would go and film it over
the shoulder over each other's shoulders
right they got more efficient with that
stuff the coverage they're like no one
wants to see these guys
that's not yeah
not a shoulder thing and in fact we
don't need all the close-ups
yeah yeah yeah just shoot straight on
everyone knows what this is
but if if humans were to go on the
internet not right now obviously because
we're here together of course being
present and mindful in space and people
listening are riveted so they're not
going to want to do anything else now
yeah and also maybe you're driving your
car you don't want to take out your
phone and start looking up old
name-brand computer ads right
but if you look at the very first ones
because they're you know they're
collected on different websites and
stuff um
they're very they have this weird the
weird over-the-shoulder angle that you
never see again a little bit
that's right that's right but for a long
time there were no there were no smart
phones
uh and so we would actually chat and
talk
oh god and then they introduced and then
they introduced the name brand computer
phone
and then you know gradually everyone got
one and everyone was using it between
takes and everyone was you know it was
it was very different
yeah perhaps violating the nda please
forgive me tim cook
but i i remember that they filmed a lot
more as you know justin than they aired
they tried a lot of different things out
there was a real shift socially in that
environment in shooting those things
once this is ironic it never occurred to
me that once that now of course you see
it played out to
not its end point but like it certainly
exploded in a way that uh has just i
mean it's just yeah i can't imagine
society now without it once we were all
able to to send text messages
to each other about you behind your back
in the mood of the set
we were just arranging parties
well you we actually did have fun
parties there were fun wrap parties on
that thing and there were that's when
the
executives who
all of whom sat in the back of the
of the set they'd all sat in the back
we'd shoot in these big warehouses uh
usually either in whatever in
professional acting we call them sound
stages
right what i call a warehouse warehouses
yeah it was it was weird we were like
you know we're in an abandoned factory
it's like i can hear pigeons is this a
problem i can hear
it was like an airport without the
planes and all the people and
for some reason there's a there's a
camaro back there with its doors off and
the engine running is that
why are we in an abandoned factory what
are all these
like oh this episode this this series of
ads is actually being directed by john
blue so
you guys do this in slow-mo while
jumping there were a lot of uh
drums filled with various uh waste
right dripping um but yeah we have we
shot down stages thank you god on sound
stage is like a professional production
that's right it was quite professional
looking and um yeah and the creative
team from media arts lab that's right
they were all in the back right they
were all on their back in the back of
this thing and and they were
uh they're all on their computers i'm
trying to i'm trying to
paint a picture of what it what it was
like all in computers around a big kind
of low to the ground um coffee table
type thing as i recall they had crea
they had created a a
a workflow a cool workflow space yeah
yeah leather couches and coffee tables
and rugs and
lamps yeah and they were all dressed a
little bit like i was dressed a little
bit like the
name brand computer that uh
they were all yeah they were all
young
hep people yeah they were hep cats
we call them now they were like
they were they were californi california
you know casual yeah right and
by cash i mean casual and cashmere like
cashmere
cashmere cashmere hoodies yeah people
know what you meant they were the ones
that were
dictating the substance of the ads
really like whenever we wanted to make
changes right making helpful suggestions
for providing creativity right
they all seemed like they were plugged
into some network uh
and
you know not totally connected to what
we were doing but but of course they
were and keeping an eye on everything um
and we were all back there doing their
jobs remotely while we were filming and
keeping an eye on the playback and then
they would throw notes to phil and phil
would throw notes to us yeah
the most enjoyable aspects of those
commercials to me would uh be the banter
between us would be the the interplay
and
in addition to the way they shot the
aesthetics of those first few
commercials they also as i recall let us
do
a lot of ad-libbing we we remember that
we got to play with each other a little
bit more yeah oh for sure and you know i
feel like that got in there a few times
yeah it did yeah but i mean they had
they had a message that they had to get
across exactly
they were i mean that's another reason
why it was 14 hour days like uh justin
and i would like 35 takes just for
ourselves from this just to fill our way
into this one right just to warm up
uh there may be something in there i
know you're not gonna use it but just
for us um yeah but then i uh
i i i remember at one of those wrap
parties this is why
it occurred to me to
mention this at one of the wrap parties
i asked one of the executives one of
those
mild-mannered very kind executives on
the computers who were now
uh a little bit
inebriated a little bit uh
you know this is a wrap party it's a
wrap party uh they're adults they can
have it of course i'm not judging them
i'm not uh judge john hodgman uh i i
podcast on wednesdays
wednesdays on maximum fun wherever you
get your podcast judge john hodgman
legacy podcast legacy legacy ten ten
years and counting okay legacy okay okay
i know judge johnny come lately you know
what i mean i do like what you're saying
i've been here a long time and you're
glaring at me as you said i've been in
this podcast game a long time
know you mean we're going on almost two
years now
what are you a child
so
but one of them said to me i i was a
little disappointed because we mentioned
all the ads we shot and then of course
the what one-fifth of them that they'd
air uh we're fun we're good we like them
but um
there were some that i just thought were
so
funny and i'm not saying we were funny
in them some we had great guest stars
like zach when galfinakis was on and
that elephanta paula tompkins there were
some that i was like god these are great
and they ended up not airing them
and uh
i remember asking them just very frankly
like hey what's the deal with that it
may have been specifically about zach's
or like rob riggle or somebody was like
that was really great jeff moores seth
morris was
although i think they did air seth no i
don't know they did intercept yeah um
but and they said to me
do you remember this and this is
something that i recently got in trouble
for but it was taken by them
why say it again
what's happening
look i just want to say to whoever is
listening from name brand computer
company i would love to do
these ads with my friend justin long i
think we had honestly
immediate instant and and powerful
comedic chemistry yeah the lights it's
like lightning in a bottle it comes
along
comes along once in a lifetime and i'm
so grateful to work with him and look
forward to doing so again soon if he
talks his way out of this job i will
throw him in there i do not
yeah i'm just close i'll drive the bus
sorry
there's jason ritter there's joe gordon
levitt i'm disposable um
you uh oh yeah are you accusing me of
killing those guys
no of potentially killing me
and then
uh working out a backroom deal with them
to replace me okay um
anyway i yeah the point is they yeah
you're right they were fun and it was
chemistry the likes of which the world's
never seen and
i'm not lying that's just honey doing
beaker that's well it's true inside yeah
i guess the world had seen it so what
did they say so what well they could
take it to them well i was too scared to
ever stand up i was on a weird fantasy
job anyway i wasn't didn't belong there
you were you were a trained actor no it
wasn't a tis tis it wasn't like what are
you guys doing it was um i mean there
may have been a little bit of like it
may have been slightly passive
aggressive but um the one time i ever
took an issue to them yeah where i felt
like on a creative point
was involving zach who i had never met
before oh you haven't
knew his work yeah
and yeah we were both fans of the mutual
friends we're huge fans
and elephantas he's talking about zach
galifianakis the famous uh comedian and
actor
and he had he had just done a video for
our future president kanye west which
was very very funny
you should have showed me on your
computer i think because i'm not sure if
we have phones the one that he shot on
his farm it's a great video yeah it's a
great video uh you don't you don't know
uh you don't cut you don't what's the
song you can't tell me nothing you can't
tell me nothing oh it's so good yeah
uh
and and uh you know
so zach
right is is this never aired zach was
playing santa claus
and zach is being zach and you know he's
got a very distinct comedic energy
and
uh
you know there was some conversation
about
you know how to how to sort of push zach
into a more conventional direction i
kind of feel like is that which i
understood was exactly to my
recollection he was playing it um
slightly drunk right he was like
i think sure yeah like an aggrieved like
oh i'm santa claus yeah
yeah kind of like
yeah and everyone knew it was funny but
like they didn't they couldn't figure
out like and there was some issue with
regard to his his look his beard
and and you know
this big red beard
and then they and then they powdered it
white that's right to look more santa
claus and they're like that's not
working that's right i i overheard
one of the creatives say to the other
one
or maybe to phil or and i overheard and
it's like maybe we need to have him
shave his beard would that be a look and
that's when i stepped in yeah
and i said
i cannot stand by i've held my piece and
i'm very grateful for this job but i
cannot stand by
while you even discuss the shaving of
one of the greatest beards in
entertainment
[Laughter]
you were right and maybe for that reason
they uh you gave up on it and they
didn't hear the act i just remember it
being
my grievance about it was that it was
the first time that it was so
clearly um one that that should have
been aired this to me was so clearly
funny like really funny because it's
zach and now everyone knows how funny
zack is but at the time
that was phil's genius is that phil was
really tapped into like what was funny
and what
the comedy scene the comedy scene yeah
obviously you know zack's
brand as you say his energy comedic
energy was i think difficult for
executives to to kind of embrace and
yeah well you know the thing is that
they weren't deciding which ads went on
right
well that's what they told me that's
what they told me at this at this party
they said
it's all coming from
jobs
yeah life could be a dream sweetheart
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again
do you ever get the chance to meet him
no no
i was so nervous about everything
you know i had
i had written this book of goofy fake
facts and it got me on the daily show
and then they got me the audition for
this ad
all and then i got the job and that all
happened within about five months at the
beginning of 2006.
and i i was thrilled and
thanks to you justin and being so
welcoming
uh and and awesome to work with and phil
and and all the all the people from
the arts lab i mean i had a lot of
support for someone who just sort of
wandered onto a set and didn't never had
been in camera i'd never been standing
up in front of a camera before i would
never have known that you were you
seemed so seasoned as a as thank you so
i was terrified of losing the job or
that i would wake up and it wouldn't
exist anymore and everything that i'd
ever made that mattered but creatively
in my life i had made on something that
steve jobs had made with his company
which we've named now uh i believe you
did jokingly i may have been talking
over it so it might still but yeah okay
well people might get be sick of the bit
by now
so when the phone was about to come out
i was at the daily show where i was
working freelance i would go in just to
work on the episodes that i was on so i
would be there every other week or so
for a few days and uh i was working on a
thursday or
or something or a friday and jon stewart
came over and said hey guess who's
coming in on monday steve jobs
and i was like oh wow why he wants to
show us the phone i'm like that's
incredible he's like yeah you should um
come
meet him and i was like i don't i don't
know john i'm a little nervous about
that
he's like why you work with him i'm like
i've never met him and you know seen so
much of you because
just to step in for a second he would
for the audience he would watch all of
it was his ultimate decision which ads
went and which ones didn't so he didn't
read the scripts beforehand because he
felt like he needed to see them all and
in his genius uh
he it worked whatever he was doing
obviously worked i just was super i just
was so afraid that he just seemed so
much like john is the point he'd seen so
many of your
your
so many of my
my pasty body parts yeah there was
there was one when i was in a hospital
nightgown which was very revealing i
remember i needed meat from all angles
but you look like you're in one floor of
the cuckoo's nest
and i was like no john i mean what i
felt was like and i said to jonas but
you know he's
he's coming here to see
you if he wanted to meet me he could
easily do you know i don't want to crash
that he goes no no no no you work here
john john is the greatest so you work
here and here's what we're gonna do uh
we'll we'll page you while he's here
and then you can come in and i'm like
i'm still not sure i don't wanna be that
guy who's like
hello yeah yes
oh i didn't know you were here yeah yeah
that actor has a very specific name he
was in the jack benny show
god see we can't we can't look at it
edwin
yes
i don't think it's edwin
anyway you think on that while i tell
you
oh okay
so the riveting tale
anyway i said well look i'll uh i'll
i'll let you know on on monday if i'm
gonna
come in
and john's like fine well that's
whatever you're whatever you're
comfortable with right
so monday evening rolls around i'm
telling this story to an acquaintance
about how i you know i all weekend i
thought about it and i decided
steve jobs can find me whenever he wants
and i have all the time in the world to
meet steve jobs
because
time is endless and we are immortal
and he said so you didn't go into the
show i'm like no and when i said that i
realized
i had made the decision to not go into
the show but i had not told john oh
no oh no
and i
called the next day and spoke to jen
flans who is still
an executive producer of the daily show
now with trevor nova so i said hi jen
listen i um decided not to come in but i
forgot to tell you she said oh i know
we were paging you oh no
oh no
yeah and i was just oh no
isn't it awful i'm sorry to
pour salt in your wound but to imagine
and which i'm sure you have steve jobs
hearing your name over and over john
hodgman paige just like waiting
bueller
insulted
and embarrassed
but you men
in this case who had to completely
changed my life oh god
oh god i also wish i could have seen you
the next time you were around jon
stewart how profusely you must have yeah
i apologize to john yeah profusely i was
just like i'm so sorry and you thought
it was funny and then steve jobs you
know i got a phone in the
in the mail a little bit early because
i'm
i'm sure yours will arrive any day now
but back in 2007
i definitely was on that list oh
interesting and i got this thing and it
was um
[Music]
you know i i remember showing it to my
friend brett martin and he said what a
world we live in and i'm like yeah i
mean
this is this is the change this is the
change right
and
that evening
i was on the phone and i had steve's
email because he had written me an email
just saying congratulations on the ads
early on
and i verify i couldn't believe that it
was him and i verified they're like yeah
he does his own email so
so i sent him a little a little email
from my phone in my bit like a thing
that was unimaginable the day before to
me from my phone in my bed i sent an
email saying thank you for
sending me this and for changing my life
et cetera et cetera and then i put it
down and i i put my little head on the
pillow start to fall asleep i was like
like what what's this i have a new email
steve jobs
responding in real time oh my god thanks
what's your favorite ringtone i'm like
no
i was like okay um now you got to go
through the ringtones and pick one yeah
now i got to get out of bed yeah yeah
just go to my office because i can't i
can't i can't some type this i got to
come up with some comedy for steve jobs
bongos
that's it go to bed
i had uh the crickets you know the the
sound of
and so i'm just i don't want to lay it
on too thick i don't want to do a whole
thing i know what it's like to get five
five paragraph emails from judge john
hodgman listeners love you but keep it
down to a sentence or two but so i'm
like keep it brief get in get out and so
i say uh well um
the uh my ringtone that i'm using right
now is crickets and i like it a lot
but i may have to switch it because it's
it's a little confusing because i often
walk around with hundreds and hundreds
of crickets in my pockets so that's
funny that's great i came up with that
that's all right you come up with that
at night good for you
well i mean we were i was younger then
and i probably had a shot of adrenaline
that like oh my god i'm corresponding
with steve jobs oh yeah oh yeah having
to respond to steve jobs is the
the the hottest drug i've ever taken
so i hit send
and i'm and i'm walking back to my bed
i'm like all right completed that
communication cycle as they say in a
notorious new religious movement i'm
about to get back
oh my god but one of my phones like
steve jobs again come on steve i'm
trying to go to bed now
this is great
and he wrote his his was lol
no it was um
[Music]
it's the one that goes
oh here i am i just i turned on the
you're looking at we're both looking no
no
we can do we're not looking at a search
engine we're looking at our that's right
we're looking on our devices and now
this podcast is going to be dead silence
for 35 minutes
catch up with
what is that
no cosmic is
no no
i think it's one of the original
so you like this
crickets is what i liked
i used to kind of like that that one got
tired ascending that's what it was
yeah let's
let's that's his favorite that was his
favorite huh yeah ascending
[Music]
i don't remember this one
i had harp for a while
who cares it's far more interesting what
he had
uh yeah so ascending was was steve jobs
jam and you know
i think about it a lot because obviously
we never had a chance to meet but very
soon after that he you know announced
his cancer and turned and um and he died
so hey when you get a chance to meet
someone who's important to your life
meet them you hear that like because
life is short every tuesdays
oh yeah i'm learning from the best wow
you slide that right into the name of
your podcast
i'm learning from you point is we we
learn every day no matter no matter how
long we live no matter how much
experience we have it is also a regret
of mine
um
not not having met uh mr jobs and not
i'm you're lucky you even corresponded
he had sent me a similar email and i
remember thinking
how
do i respond to this how do i adequately
respond and um i remember thinking we're
going to see him at that i thought we
were going to be doing a thing
up at out of uh palo alto do you
remember that there was talk of that us
going up there and doing a presentation
um
and i remember thinking i'm going to see
him in person i'm going to have it i'm
going to have the opportunity to say all
this to him uh an email seems
like trivial and i won't be able to
express so i never
wrote him it's scary it's scary yeah
steve jobs yeah yeah the respect i had
for him was um and still is uh you know
immeasurable so
um it's a shame but we're lucky we got
to do him obviously and and uh we're
lucky that uh as as people who on this
earth that we got to have him for the
time we did
tompkins was also
also played with santa claus
oh yes yes he tells a story in his
incredible show laboring under delusions
i encourage you to listen to the live
from the bell house version because you
can hear me in the audience
you're laughing or heckling well i got
really freaked out because
he uh he it's just it's a the whole show
is about various jobs that he had in his
life
including various retail jobs including
one where he worked in a novelty hat
store in philadelphia called bats in the
belfry i heard him saying that i can
hear him saying that
he has such a great voice that's right
he really enunciates well that's right
that's right yeah that's good yeah yeah
yeah that's right one time one time i
did my oh that's right like a gentleman
like yes he's like an old entertainer
like a carnival barker almost one time i
was at a hanging out with paul
and i and i did a little of paul back to
paul paul did not like it oh really
yeah yeah yeah yeah i just did just a
little paul yeah that's that's right
that's great go on
that's great
i just it was one of those things where
you just hear like oh you're a band is
like this is my favorite band yes and if
you're a musician you've got to keep
that out of your head he tells a story i
think that illustrates the feeling about
steve jobs in a similar way which is
what he was he had he had a role
a supporting role uh and there will be
blood
and daniel day-lewis
uh uh
uh look i don't have to use a search
engine to know that he was also in the
movie i think that's right he played um
i freaking yeah he had something that
has hit a role in this tompkins movie
so he was a millionaire salesman that's
right
paul paul of tompkins tells the story
about like
uh you know
he knew that daniel day-lewis didn't
break character on set
and he also
knew that he was famous for
being intense yeah and the way basically
what he says no one told me
he was the most intense
yeah no and like walking walking working
on a set with daniel day lewis just
sitting down
it was like there's a there's a there's
a jungle cat in the room
and it's freaking everybody out
and that's what i mean it's like that's
why when steve jobs emails you you feel
like you're getting
a a telegram from a fictional character
centaur yes you know it's like i don't
how do i what could i possibly say back
i know it's like a postcard from gandhi
you know like this can't be it's also
like it's surreal to the point where
you don't even know how to yeah i
i don't know where to begin formulating
a response back but yours
but you did it right i think i mean in
terms of getting that email i got out of
b i got out of bed you got you made the
effort as you should so i made the
effort which by the way during these
times getting out of bed is yeah it's a
dream effort yes yes and and like john i
know you regret not having met him but
um how cool that that you connected at
all in that way and and he i'm sure he
was more than appreciative of your work
because you were so great on those
in those ads you were just so funny and
and you gave so much to those things
that
uh i'm i'm sure he really uh you were
good to you you were also good no yeah
but i just whatever i whatever i loved
it and and um i'm sure i'm sure daddy
loved both of us
yeah but we'll never know you're right
right oh well well our step daddy was
phil
and i i do know phil loves both of us we
got phil morrison the director and we we
got to see him not that long ago well
now of course it seems like years ago
but everything feels like 2000 years ago
i know i know what's going how is your
family without being too specific is
everybody home is everybody there well
uh
so i i am uh married and my wife and i
have two human children um i'm happy to
talk about all of them although i i
refuse to name my children or put them
on social media primarily so
uh to ensure that they do not get more
famous than i am
i don't want to give them a leg up i
don't need any competition from the
youth
cause they're gonna they would have more
because i know your daughter and she is
very charming and she would have more
followers in i mean i would give it a
week
uh
my wife's name is catherine
that's a real name
it's a real name yeah um but you know i
think back you know they were little
little little kids when we started you
know hodgman hodgmine is
uh now attending college at an unnamed
four-year accredited institution in
southern connecticut
yeah i remember
you were very kind to come to a play i
did a year and a half ago and uh
and you brought hajimena and she was um
really sweet uh and it blew my mind i i
had it was such an oh i've been having
them
with uh greater frequency these old man
moments um
and that was one that was one that
really stuck out where i
you know when you're younger and like
you run into older relatives and oh my
god and they're so incredulous by how
big you've gotten right and you think
okay enough i'm like
and i felt that way about hajimena that
i was like no you don't understand i saw
you when you were at little i know i
know it was so sweet and you came out
after the show and
and i felt you because that's i mean you
know you
as a as a parent you watched them grow
up slowly yeah it's like it's like
weight gain like you don't notice it
happening yes all of a sudden yes you're
four months into weird how it was weird
how when you came out after the play
you're like
uh hodgmina you've grown so much and
john you've really let yourself go like
but that's fair
you know that's the greatest thing in
the world to you know
you know to go see a play first of all
it's great to see your friend on stage
and also you know
uh to be there with you know a person
who's started out
needing your help to learn about culture
and now is teaching you things
it was just terrific and that was a
great that must be quite a moment john
to have those and i'm sure you have them
all the time now but um
those moments of realization where
they've they're their own person now and
they've they're autonomous uh
yeah yeah no i mean that's that's true
from the moment they're born right yeah
that's hard that's the hard part like
you can dress them up and stuff but
they're not your pets and you gotta stay
out of their way i learned that from
hear that mom
yeah
um
why by the way wendy i love the shirt
that justin's wearing today good choice
uh but i will say you know to to what we
were talking about you know steve jobs
changed our lives dramatically in
different ways and yeah
i do regret not meeting him but
you know that lesson
that uh life is short
uh was very much brought home
um by by
you know his passing and and the fact
that i i still even though by that time
i was
you know a parent i mean a parent not
it's clear that i'm visible right but
a parent both yeah i was still tapped
into some of that old immortality
instinct you have when you're in your
20s or whatever and especially with
somebody
i'm grateful for the lesson to
be mindful of the moments that you're in
what has become of his legacy would you
say um the good plus number one 100
great all the products are fantastic
one thing that happened with the iphone
not to be a pitch a pitchman for apple
but people are concerned obviously and
understandably about surveillance
uh
you know the culture of surveillance
that we live in the cameras everywhere
facial recognition etc etc
but the iphone put
a connected internet camera in so many
hands all around the world until 2007
when the iphone came out it was still
largely the province of fairly affluent
mostly white
nerdy and or businessy and or student-y
people right
the iphone put a hand
the iphone put a computer and the
internet and a camera
in the hands of more people than it ever
had those things before in history and a
lot of those hands
are non-white hands and that's been
incredible
right it's an incredible need of
transparency and some sort of tool
uh to reveal these injustices because
surveillance goes both ways right that's
true for better you know however you
feel about
cameras everywhere
one thing is true is that the
the pattern
of uh
police violence against uh non-white
people
black people particularly
is a pattern because that was a big
debate that was going on which shouldn't
even be a debate but still is like is
this a few bad apples or is this a
pattern and it was very comfortable
until
you see the video and you see the next
video and you see the next video and you
are forced to realize unless you resist
it that it's not disconnected galaxies
there's stars that form a constellation
they form a picture
they form
you know a pattern
and the pattern is violence and yeah
and to a student of history such as
yourself this is probably not surprising
this is probably not something that is
uh
revelatory it's first of all my major is
in in literary theory
so
yes but you know a lot about history and
and what i one of the reasons i love
areas of my expertise that trilogy that
trilogy excuse me is that um
there are all of those
uh untruths that you those yarns that
you spend there
they have a
there's a basis of of truth in them yeah
even the the biggest lies have have to
have some some they have to resonate off
of a
truth and and you know in areas of my
expectation and on the daily show too
it's be like yeah
you know the the gag the quote unquote
joke would be that
they call you know economics isn't
called the dismal science because it's
grim it's named for
sir eustis dismal
the british economist who first
proposed making smoke stacks out of
children during the
during the
industrial revolution
you know that's that's a fun joke about
child labor right well see that's the
thing it's uh the truth is that there
there were such grim
morbid aspects of child labor that that
um joke is just shining a light it's
what i've been talking about portlandia
we have carrie brownstein on it's one of
the reasons i love portland is because
uh it doesn't it's it it only it leans
slightly into the
uh the truth to make it absurd but it it
highlights the absurdity of something
that is already
a truth that is already exist yeah i
mean that that's the thing it's like the
the abs there is absurdus humor there's
dada humor
like in comedy
if someone just comes out and goes
orange
and then
flops on the stage and then i don't know
that's just a non-sequitur right
yeah i don't think any i don't think any
form of creative communication comedy or
drama or whatever is gonna
truly make a connection unless you're
showing something of yourself that's
true that's true you know
life could be a dream
[Music]
[Music]
you always really downplayed any acting
skill that you had and um
i it always confounded me because to me
you are such a present natural
actor and what you were doing was so you
were finding success doing that so
it never made sense to me but then i
started seeing you in uh popping up in
movies and television shows and uh are
have you now come to terms with the fact
that you are an actor
the moment i be i came to terms with the
fact that i'm an actor is precisely when
i stopped getting hired oh that's funny
that's funny right
no i mean or you had been like i'm not
an actor but i'll do this part on board
to death and then they dry up and you're
like well wait a minute i'm an actor
yeah no i mean i love i
i don't want to say past tense but i
mean it's certainly during this
particular time
it's harder than ever to get in front of
a camera but i love i love it and the
only reason i down played my skills is
that first of all there are people much
more skilled but much like stand-up
comedy it's like i was not trained nor
did i come up through the traditional
dues paying process i paid different
dues in a different way you were an
editor for a long time right a little
literary editor i was a literary agent
and then i was a
magazine journalist is that what you
wanted to do when you went to yale by
the way it must have been a thrill to
just to get into yale do you remember
your parents were your parents why are
you saying yale yale yeah what am i
saying yale how do i come to get into to
get into yale
i might give you an experience
i was wondering if i'd been pronouncing
it wrong
y-a-y
first word right yeah and then e-l-l-e
yay l it's name yeah it's the university
named after superman's grandmother
that's for the yeah
sherelle and yale
what am i i'm just it's yeah
i was born there i should know this you
were born in yale new haven hospital i
don't know yeah i never told you this
but i was the doctor who delivered you
how could you not have told me that
that's that's just i forgot were you
just waiting until we were on a podcast
together no i just forgot until just now
just i finally put it together
well you've been oh
long right that's how i know you
right and jim kept passing out damn
he kept muttering under his breath oh
not another one i got to tell you jim
you didn't make much of an impression i
thought your name was doug for half of
the half of the labor
anyway i played i played an obstetrician
on baby mama so
that's right that's right you did
uh when you were going to school there
you was it to become a writer was that
always the dream no i didn't know i
didn't know what and to give you a sense
of how absurdly privileged was i didn't
think it mattered i mean i was i i grew
up
look i i have a lot of white privilege
but
both of my parents came from very
traditional working-class catholic
families in central massachusetts and
philadelphia specifically
not families with a lot a lot of
generational wealth that's not the kind
of privilege i had but i look the way i
do so for the most part
you know american society has always
treated me like a full human being
yeah yeah well it's like you know that
round face baby man
is disgusting but he's a white guy so we
give him a pass he's still a full human
being we're not gonna we're not gonna
make him prove that he has a right to
exist
and i was an only child so i had the
benefit of parents who
uh my mom was no longer alive but
parents who
loved each other and took care of each
other and took care of me
and that's the most incredible privilege
of all right yeah and they they were
they were professionals my mom was a are
an rn my dad worked in various business
ventures kind of a business white collar
guy
and they saved money to send me to
college so i didn't have loans right so
none of that sacrifice work
made me think that i should direct my
college education towards something
i just felt like oh the job is
to go to this incredibly picturesque
disneyland of a college yeah and have a
great time and meet people and
read books and flowers
they never made you feel guilty or aware
of how much they had sacrificed it never
felt like a bird it had been a burden no
i tried to give the same privilege to
my own children it's like you have your
own lives do you go you go do it it's
fine
my dad did say to me
before i went to college you can study
whatever you want do whatever you want
i'm only asking you like at some point
in college just take one
class in bookkeeping and accounting
um you know
learn how to
how to how to you know do finances like
balance your finances balance a
checkbook balance a run a spreadsheet
write a business proposal perhaps
because he's a business guy and he
started as an accountant that's the only
thing that i would ask you to do and i
said sure thing dad nope
never did it no really never did it
totally i would have said the same thing
if my if doug long had given me that
good advice yeah i just swanned around i
just swarmed around reading interesting
books and meeting interesting people
and i i regret nothing you know what i
mean like i i
uh i thought that i might i mean i i got
into books because books seemed
important
and meaningful and substantive and i
wanted those i wanted to be interesting
that way but i always loved comedy and
television and film i was intimidated by
a lot of what went on at yale and i i
covered up for my fear
by refusing to be a joiner of anything
so i felt much more comfortable just
sitting in the library alone reading
books and hanging out with friends and
stuff and making jokes but i wasn't
gonna i wasn't gonna join an improv
group right or i wasn't gonna join a
singing group or i wasn't gonna audition
for a play comfortable outside on the
outside and outside cause i was afraid
they're gonna tell me i was afraid they
were gonna tell me no
i knew that that was gonna happen i was
terrified that it would happen and i
tried to put it off and only later in
life did i appreciate like
rejection and being rejected as part of
life and you sometimes people aren't
into what you're doing and sometimes
you're not going to get the job that you
think is your perfect fate i spent seven
years at a literary agency
it was my first job out of college i
loved my colleagues i loved working in
the world of books i loved taking a nap
on the leather sofa
but i knew that i wanted to do something
creative right and i was scared to do it
another thing that i
write about in vacation land is my mom
died and that was a life is too short
moment for me
where i appreciated oh um i have been
away from my job at the literary agency
taking care of my mom for months
and
the world has gone on without me we're
all limited in our time here
and i don't want to work at a literary
agency and i was terrified that i would
say
i was terrified that i would say this to
my clients
and they would be mad at me for having
wasted their time but they're like oh
yeah no you go you go do the thing
i'm lucky that i had the opportunity to
work for the daily show and for apple
obviously because it thrust me into
these incredibly weird and uncomfortable
situations
and you don't want to run from them you
want to embrace them when the world
offers you something
that gives you a chance to give
something of yourself you know you
should say yes right
and
for a long time because of the
popularity of the ads and the daily show
and the currency of those both of those
things
i was getting offers to do stuff like
jonathan names as an old friend of mine
from the literary world of new york
offered me a role on board to death
which i loved i got to kiss zach
alphinakis on the beardy lips and i was
going on auditions which i didn't i'd
never done before and that is just
pure immersion therapy and rejection yes
yes from well said getting back to phil
and the apple commercials oops uh
phil morrison it i i think now it's like
really hitting me what a chance he took
and and for him to see that in you and
your abs i mean yeah phil was the reason
that i was in that room and it wasn't
until i knew because i had auditioned
once and it's i mean you will understand
it but like it's it's truly
an experience of
true humiliation
routine psychological humiliation
to be called in to go into a room and
you feel like you're making a hostage
video
and they don't give you any feedback and
you're looking into this dead
camcorder circa 1989 you don't know
who's ever going to look at it you know
already that you don't have the job i
mean you're if you're auditioning you
don't have the job because that means
if you're smart enough you know that
they've offered this role to someone and
they're waiting for here that person
says yes or no and then you try it right
just the experience of just being bared
in that way it builds you yeah well so
i couldn't like going into the first
audition i was like well that was a
weird story to tell
getting the call back which was
surprising to me
i was still like why am i here what am i
doing and phil was in the room and he
said i know you from the daily show so i
suggest you be here and i'm like that
then i know why i'm here and that gave
me a permission to really lean in
and give everything that i had i don't
make this too sewn together perfectly
but i am america's greatest storyteller
you know all those times that i would i
wouldn't join in
join a group or or join the play or
or audition for the thing or put myself
out there
for fear of failing i remember that
moment in that room being like
well phil's here
i know i'm here for a reason and i know
that reason is me
if i lose the role it's because i don't
give enough i'm not going to get the
role by holding back holding back out of
fear out of out of politeness out of
feeling like i don't belong here once i
knew that i was there that phil wanted
me there and i was the reason that i was
there
i was like i'm gonna lean into this and
it's like pc starts beat boxing and i
remember jonah welber back in brookline
high school teaching me how to beat box
and hum at the same time
[Music]
you know like that that was still a
relatively novel thing to do in in
comedy and culture at that time yeah
yeah i mean that was that was the the
lesson like that's the say say yes like
yeah yeah don't go into the room and say
no to yourself say yes to yourself and i
allowed myself to accept that
i wanted this job i have to be a part of
this i have to learn how it works i have
to learn how to write these
these desk bits i have to learn how to
collaborate with the writers on the
daily show i can't be precious i have to
you know
let my jokes be shot down and not be
hurt
learn how to audition and throw myself
into it and not be afraid and not be
ashamed well i'm not telling uh people
anything they don't already know but uh
i would say certainly on the apple
commercials you you you did that i mean
you you did that in a way that um i
always really admired uh i was always a
little jealous of you because you got to
do the really fun you got to do the
goofy i was the goofy one i mean yeah
beaker just goes meat meet me right
right right honeydew gets all the lines
and he often gets blown up and i i'm so
grateful to phil i'm grateful to you for
um
for for in that room in that moment
learning that lesson because who knows
who would have been cast and sound
sounds like it sounds like you're
wrapping up i got it message received
look i got a family i got to go home to
dinner
i got you yeah i'm grateful for you i
love you very much i love you too okay
okay i would like to talk for another
hour i know me too i know i try to save
face here and say i'm out of time but
really
i could go and
can you just leave this zoom open can we
i i
oh my god i meant uh i know i love you
uh
what is your most commonly used emoji
martini glass
oh yeah no kidding
okay cheers
and that's to punctuate uh hey can't
wait to see something like that can't
wait to have a martini okay okay
specific okay if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play uh uh a sport is like a um a
game
with often you with a ball or something
like that yeah um like the strategy and
the
points uh
t team stroke are we talking about are
we talking about team sport or it would
have to be athletics something more of a
solitary personal perfection like um
if it's rock climbing or painting
yeah
it's can you not think of a sport that
you
you i can't tennis okay okay there you
go
well well no but if you had to if you
had to be a professional
okay
okay maybe doubles maybe you played
doubles
because that's because you can you can
it's kind of sedentary yeah and you can
sit i mean if you're playing right
fielders beautiful parks yeah
okay
okay yeah
i like to i like tennis i like i move
around i can't i get my stencil um if
you could have one snack food for the
rest of your life what would it be i
know the drink but what would you pair
that that um what would i pair with a
fine martini um
puffy cheetos coffee cheetos puffy no
you know not the crunchy cheetos but oh
yeah they make puffy ones now yeah i
like also planters cheese balls are good
i like butts brand that's right i like
us i like a lot of nuts yeah i'm
thinking back down to like the craft
service because we had a lot of time to
enjoy craft service and we had a great
craft service
that's right you were always enjoying a
moxie soda if they had them i do enjoy
moxie soda i like it every time i think
of you
yeah it's like the fago of the northeast
right or or the or the or the cheerwine
of the northeast oh it's your one i
don't know um and then what else
carolina
uh diet dr pepper diet dr pepper i like
that uh i like diet moxie i like diet
sodas yeah but uh but snack wise like a
jacks jack jacks
oh john you would love uh pirate's booty
now makes a uh a cheese puff oh yeah i
could get i could i could [ __ ] with that
oh you could uh and it would yeah
i think i think you'd enjoy it because
it's a little bit it's it's less
chemically crazy salty tasting
than a jax but it's got the same
satisfaction
you know that kind of cheesy crunchy
yeah delicious i like a pork rind i like
uh oh yeah i like uh i like an utz dark
kettle dark russet kettle chip
uh yeah wow these are all snacks but i
guess probably
number one with a bullet
like the one that i just can't
resist is a cheat is a cheeto of some
kind or you know what i mean a cheese
yeah puff cheese cheese puffed cheese
bright orange thing uh i'm with you um
yeah what's your favorite movie of all
time uh miller's crossing is the first
thing that comes to mind oh wow wow um
love that memory but i yeah i that's
that's one i can you know
no one has a favorite i know
i feel like no i feel like if you if you
have a favorite movie then maybe you
don't like movies that much because if
you like movies
then they are a million different
flavors i mean you have a
you have some touchstones that are
meaningful to you in different ways very
very good point uh and in quarantine
what's oh you've gotten to show your
kids uh grey gardens gray gardens is one
of my favorite movies jaws oh great yeah
you know the amazing jaws yeah maisel
brothers directed jaws it was a
documentary about a shark
right after they make great gardens they
went out they went out tomorrow one of
them passed away
mysteriously
yeah great gardens um
sure you like that i'm sure you'd like
to cut that shark open see the remains
of these famous documentary makers all
over this dock that's your name in the
national geographic
that's really good it's not a great
richard dreyfuss impressed is that
richard no that's that's a mayor of the
mayor yeah
the actor's name i can't remember but is
it crazy oh just look it up um if you
could have if you had to live somewhere
else where would it be maine
yep yeah
um if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met
who would they be uh steve jobs got to
make it up to him
well finally steve
sorry good news for you steve
say peter comes to him sorry to drag you
from the beyond
uh
so let's see
if i'm starting with steve jobs and as
someone i've never met
right
[Music]
or never had
james baldwin james baldwin
just saw i just was watching a bunch of
his interviews on uh dick cavett on
youtube uh yeah he's a fascinating uh
yeah but i mean you see him being
interviewed and he's like oh we've
always been here um
uh we got to do better we got to do
better
not everything that is faced
can be changed but nothing can be
changed unless it is faced
wow james baldwin i saw that on the sign
outside of a
vintage clothes store and windsor
terrace uh all right and the third third
guy i'm i'm not going to say you're
wrong so we can't look it up but that it
does sound more like stephen
uh and then someone i've never
met oh um
[Music]
uh edith bouvier beale
younger the younger the young the young
little lady yeah that is uh
or octavia butler the science fiction
writer actually i'm gonna i'm gonna
leave a little edie alone she's had her
moment okay okay um
who uh who's your favorite muppet
speaking of
kermit
yeah
yeah you were a muppet guy grown up
oh yeah i was there i first run i was
watching them as yeah
you know i i was offered a job
on uh season two of the tick on amazon
starring the great incredibly funny
peter sarafinowicz and the equally
incredibly funny griffin newman they
they had called me up as they always do
when whenever i'm being thought about
for a role or being offered a role uh
will you shave because you look terrible
and i have grown affection for this dead
animal that's on my face it's called a
beard
and i'll go i would prefer not to and
there's often this sort of standoff
until
you know i i give in but in this case
in this case i didn't give in i was like
no i really don't want to shave my beard
i think
and so when i'm having my makeup done
and i've shaved my beard down to look a
little bit more tame
ben comes in and goes and he was the one
who asked me to shave initially and and
he goes and you know um the sweetest
guys
along with the tic tv show on amazon is
one of the great things
that not enough people watch and i urge
you to do it because you know we were
thinking of you for this world because
particularly this character
um you know i was part of the reason why
i was suggesting your shave but i
understand you don't want to it's fine
but in terms and i don't want to tell
you how to i want to get in your head in
terms of the performance but when i was
writing the character i was kind of i
don't know if you ever watched the
muppet show and i'm like
oh man bunsen honeydew and he's like yes
i'm like
yeah
i got you i know exactly what you're
going for like like that was a note
where it's like no i i now snapped in on
exactly what you want i have snapped in
exactly what i want
and even though i'm not shaven i'm going
to give you a whole lot of dew a whole
lot of honeydew
and if you watch me in season two of the
tick i am doing i'm doing muppet hands
the entire oh god
well
bunsen i think was one of my favorites
in part most of my when i think about my
favorite muppets it's uh like swedish
chef they were the ones that
incorporated human hands and didn't care
for swedish chef cause you saw the hands
that's what i liked that yeah i liked it
honeydew his hands were still that
yellow optic yellow right right but
swedish chef those were those were jim
henson's actual hands but they weren't
human hands i mean they were human hands
no no no but they could they do now but
they didn't then oh really look at the
beginning look it up when this podcast
is over and you're allowed to use the
internet again oh i've seen check out
some og swedish chef clips it's uh it's
not fun it's not fun to see
okay all right
um uh if you had to be one age for the
rest of your life physically what would
you pick uh i would say
uh
44
okay yeah i was in terrific shape i'm
49.
i was in terrific shape in 2015. why
you know i had changed my i was
exercising a lot i was i was
con
a cardio conditioned uh
and um i just looked back uh at those
photos and i i had lost
a lot of weight
between 2013 and 25. i remember that
yeah yeah and and it was it was just not
eating so much all the time and you know
diet and exercise
okay and everything was really clicking
for me
in 2015 as well as i was not just
physically in decent shape
but emotionally very happy as well and
and i am still you know what i mean but
i had i had the wisdom of of my years i
had the success
that i had enjoyed i was not aching
you know when people
when people reach middle age
that's often when they look back on
their lives
and say i wish i had done x y and z and
here i am now confronting
the the very jaws of death
uh i am extremely lucky um as and as i
suspect you are when you
get even older there are certain things
yeah i mean you know like um
i i i knew in 2015
as i know now as i enter into my 50s
like
i've i've done my life's work like i
love what i created yeah and i and i
don't have a regret about it and i'm
glad that i'm still able to do stuff so
i'm very very lucky to not face
an abyss of of failure and regret and i
have that i had that feeling at 45.
excuse me at 44.
as a plus
a [ __ ] incredible body
if you could be
if you could be reincarnated as a
non-human animal uh what would it be
well not any kind of fish or porpoise or
anything because that seems boring as f
a porpoise seems boring they seem to
like they're having so much fun and not
jumping around no they're stuck they
breathe well they breathe air but
they're stuck underwater it's terrible
yeah worst of both worlds also they're
smart they're not they're not stupid
they they might have some existential
dread yeah they're really smart they're
not they're not dumb they're not dumb
like beluga whales
stupid
uh
i don't like i'd like to fly
but i don't want to but i want to be a
mammal i don't want to
be a bird
bat
the
weird ungainly looking creatures
okay i'd be a cat i'd be a cat be a cat
today okay i'm picturing you as a cat
it's really funny
which um which golden girl do you most
identify with dorothy blanche rose or
sophia
which one is b arthur that's blanche i'm
sorry
what are you trying to charge me
sorry i'm that stupid
sorry i'm gonna light up buzzfeed john
hodgman doesn't know the names of the
golden girl characters
he thought b arthur played blanche
in this selectively edited podcast clip
we show that john hodgman
has lost the faith of america
dorothy no dorothy is dorothy is the
older the oldest one yes yes
arthur the arthur yeah i can see that
and then
and dogs for cats we answered that uh
cats i would say in terms of being yes
no or in terms of having owning i've
only ever had cats
um beetles are the rolling stones if you
had to pick one beetles
okay do you have a song a favorite song
uh i can't get no satisfaction by the
wrong stunts
okay okay
um
and uh
do you ever think about how you wanna be
remembered uh both as a
as a performer as a creative person and
uh
and as a person
the wealthiest man on earth
yeah what else what a touching what a
touching tribute that's the one thing i
haven't accomplished yesterday
well uh
i i think i would like to be remembered
as um
uh
smart and kind
two things that don't often go together
in my estimation in my life you're uh
one of the kindest one of the smartest
you know how much i love you and i'm
gonna talk about it on the show um but i
really do and oh is this just a
pre-interview
yeah yeah so let me know when you're
rolling on your end and we'll get into
it okay
all right good but i hope i gave you
some uh some points of entry there
that sounds gross um i i do i love you
and i'm so grateful that you did those
commercials you know the best thing
about
this difficult situation is
that
we get to see each other even though we
can't be together which is very nice
and also you don't have to smell me
because i forgot to shower and i can see
it's bad it's fairly i
this is i can see that you smell yeah i
know that's how bad it is
yeah justin i love you very much it's so
great to spend time with you and yeah
let's do some more spending time
together in the future we can it doesn't
have to be on a podcast um i was
suggesting that i'd be the permanent
guest of this podcast oh okay
let me run that up the flagpole
tell
you know it doesn't pay if if your goal
is to become the wealthiest person it's
not it you might have more difficulty
achieving that all right how do i hit uh
leave me
well that just happened well that was
that your bunsen honeydew yeah oh is
that good yeah it was pretty good
had you well that just happened yes
that's right well that happened yeah
speak i i want to hear him again
bunsen honeydew i haven't seen those in
a while but didn't it looks and sounds
like it's amazing he really leans into
that when you were like you know you
have a bit of a bunsen honey he's like
oh yes
yeah well most people wouldn't embrace
that comparison but he's so uh
willingly
i really appreciate that he did that i
think part of why he was able to play pc
so well is um
because he he has a realistic
understanding of like what he
looks like and what he and he played it
to like such great effect he's honest
he's honest and he was able to be
uh he played that buffoon part really
well you do have a bunsen honeydew
beaker dynamic i
i mean we're so off he's way more bunsen
than you are beaker you're not that
beaker uh i'm a little i am more beaker
than i was in those commercials see in
the commercials i was playing a guy who
kind of had their [ __ ] together and was
like
more confident about what they were
saying certainly about computers right
like i knew you know i was the polar
opposite in life but um our real life
dynamic is a lot closer to
a beaker bunsen honeydew thing because
he'd be like what are you talking about
right speaker you know and i'd be like
really frenetic and uh
so yeah that makes sense
you know and and i'll like just try
something without thinking about it it's
funny i think one of the reasons those
commercials were as successful as they
were is because of the chemistry that
you guys have and i
i mean from my perspective from an
audience perspective it seemed like that
was there right away it was effective
because you had this like perfectly
antagonistic dynamic in those
commercials because they were there was
antagonism built into those spots but
there was like real
friendship you know it was like
it was like uh laurel and hardy you know
where they're friends but they're like
always frustrated with each other
yeah
but you but you need both yeah it can't
just be
antagonistic because then it's like why
do i want to watch these guys who don't
like each other
because it's like you love each other
yeah we had that right i mean i felt
that way about him i'm trying to
remember now when i first met him we
first started doing i think i just so
respected you know you could tell he's
smart and funny right away you've met
within like two minutes
he is um just so clearly smart and funny
um and i think i really respect those
things and uh and he was nice to
everyone i mean so
that combination it's smart funny and
nice it's rare that's a that's a good
one two three yeah and and when it's so
apparent like with somebody like john
it's
you get all three of those things within
you know and a warmth within like a few
minutes of meeting him so i did to
your point i i liked him right away and
i
wanted to and he was good and also then
it's like you get out there in front of
the cameras and
and i realized that he was being
subtle and he was listening to me and it
was like oh thank god i got a partner
like this because
you know i it was my fee i had such fear
about doing those commercials i thought
i was afraid of being
you know time to make the donuts or
whatever it was like um
even though that guy's i'll talk about
iconic and to this day people still call
you mac yeah yeah so there's i mean that
stuck
to a degree it did and who knows how it
affected
movies and stuff like that with me i you
know i i drive myself i could drive
myself
allowed you to buy some pretty cool
properties sure did yeah and
i got to meet john and i
and it did lead to some jobs i know like
i think die hard i think that's how
bruce was aware of me india oh really
yeah and it had a computer element to
that too and so
i think it led to now who knows but but
it was um right away i i just was so
grateful that he was somebody i could
play with and and it wasn't like hey hey
everyone here's a uh mac computers are
the best and i'm gonna tell you why
and it was that thing they wanted me to
do that hey i'm i'm a mac you know they
wanted me to deliver it like that oh
really yeah yeah i've never told you
this no yeah the first time we did why
would they want that that seems so
obviously annoying every direction was
and poor phil morrison who we talked
about uh phil also has a very grounded
he likes comedy to be very you know real
and grounded and it was going against
his instincts whenever the executives
would come over and whisper in his ear
uh and phil would go okay
justin they they want you to just be
proud of being a mac and like so instead
of you know i was just i was trying to
throw it away because i wanted the whole
thing to be as thrown away as possible
and you don't want to be smug smug
because they're inherently smug yeah
those the spots are like i'm better than
you so they wanted me to come out
instead of saying hello i'm a mac just
normal they wanted me to say
hello i'm a mat that's so strange that
they would crowd instinct i know it's
amazing that he uh had never acted
before he and he talked about how
nervous he was when he started doing
them because he had no experience but i
never would have i know guessed that i
know i had such a uh confidence about
him he and and i know the p i know
his colleague had been offered the job
before i think he knows this so it's not
a big reveal he knows it
i hope he does rob cordrey was was gonna
play that part but then i heard rob
wanted to
i think rob told me years later he
wanted to play my part
so that's why he didn't do it doesn't he
also seem like he would be funny in any
era like
yes like that's like an old-timey yes
yeah like i could picture him uh
entertaining lincoln uh lincoln or like
at a dinner party you know like yes yeah
like like oscar wilde yeah he i could
see him getting along with oscar wilde
he yeah which also i think it speaks to
how
i think a lot of comedy has fallen apart
over the years and has become
kind of crass er and cruder that his
brand of comedy like super intellectual
comedy i think of
as a more like old fashioned thing now i
know i know like with um where he's able
to play with language and he's a humor i
mean he really is a humorous yeah yeah
like when he in his book when he he's
he's really it's funny to hear him talk
about his facial hair he's really
eloquently funny about his facial hair
uh but he he references like i'm trying
to i forget the president i think i
think grover cleveland or william howard
taft he references
somebody who has that old-timey he's
just so quick with historical writers
hell of a brain oh my god yeah a real
bunsen honeydew brain yes that's steve
jobs story is great i know um i know
it's such a good story that he told and
it's crazy that you never met him and
i i didn't realize that he um
that steve jobs
saw all the
commercials oh yeah and picked the one i
didn't know that oh you didn't know that
no so yeah can you matt like he was so
familiar
with you yeah the two of you i know it's
seen so much footage of you
like that that alone is crazy to wrap
your head around that someone like him
who's this
this le icon
he's so familiar with you and then you
never
and we're so unfamiliar with him i i
know him as a obviously
you know as a
person in history and
in the context of like what the empire
the company he created and all that but
uh
i know i i've written
john talks about his own regret but i i
have my own too i mean i would love to
have met him i laughed so hard when uh
when you asked what sport he'd
want to play professionally he said well
i guess i'd rather be on a team
because then i wouldn't have to play as
much
i really like the way his brain works
yeah i know he's fantastic oh yeah
fantastic brain he really does this i've
always admired it and sometimes i get um
i want his like intellectual approval
yeah i get it i would too
it was so funny when he said
why are you saying
yale yeah yale how do you say it yale
yell yale yale
it's one syllable it's i guess it's sort
of tricky yale yale yale am i still
doing it a little bit yale yale well now
i'm thinking too much about it oh
there's harvard dartmouth yale
that's better okay oh okay maybe i have
to say it in a group series
um hey let's read a letter uh okay this
is a letter from
alyssa will subject greetings from one
pair of siblings to another dear justin
and christian my sister and i are
currently living in the two separate
states i alyssa m in california taking
care of our 90 year old grandpa wow
while teaching high school singing and
acting class is over soon
cool must be fun or annoying and casey
is in illinois uh an english professor
at a university maneuvering this
complicated world of teaching during
covet while being so far away from
family casey and i are very close and
are used to traveling back and forth to
see each other several times a year but
because of covid it has been nearly a
year now since we've been able to see
one another in person
she says it's really rough not knowing
if we'll ever be able to get together
for the holidays this year i stumbled on
your podcast a few months ago and
quickly had to share with casey that's
cool
um we're here
we're huge genslinger fans
kenslinger so the new girl episodes were
especially fun to listen to but your
sibling banter is such a highlight of
every episode as sisters who are always
making fun of one another coming up with
bits and laughing over inside jokes we
found your dynamics so relatable
that's cool your podcast has been one of
the things that we've been able to laugh
about and connect over through this
difficult time and it's been a real
comfort thank you for your honest and
authentic discussions and all the laughs
in between thank you alyssa
that is that's very nice
um casey so back to listen casey came up
with a would you rather that's a little
specific to us
whoa i'm i'm an opera singer and casey's
a huge fan of the office
but we thought it could lead to some
pretty
profound debating
would you rather okay here we go would
you rather have to spontaneously burst
into song to express yourself
i feel like we've had that this one like
you're in a musical but no one else is
singing you've done this it's funny i
love this one or i don't mind doing this
one again it's fun to think about
or break the fourth wall and narrate to
the camera
talking about people who are currently
around you like they're not there i also
love doing that that's a fun bit that i
used to i used to do with an
ex-girlfriend going
ah can you believe this one you see what
i'm dealing with but but what's the
camera in this case but everyone can
still hear and see um just like off to
the side yeah like yeah have you ever
done that where it's like are you
kidding me with this one you just kind
of turn your head to like a fake camera
uh i i guess i've seen you do that maybe
yeah speaking of ferris bueller by the
way they do that a lot in ferris buelle
but they do to the camera yeah yeah
that's true that's true well but just
pretend like it came out you know ferris
bueller's day off is a movie right
but you just have to basically you have
to turn away from whoever you are i get
it i get it all right um
in both of these you are the only person
doing this everyone else is just
watching another catch is that you're
singing oh you're singing is not good
and always off key and every time you
break the fourth wall well that makes it
very hard for me to imagine average
yeah
try if you can
it's hard i've got a nice voice
[Laughter]
guilty is charged
i can't imagine my voice not sounding
like an angel
uh and every time you break the fourth
wall you have to reference tom brady's
attractiveness people would think you're
a delusional homosexual
constantly talking about tom brady i
mean like uh or singing i
guess i would
it would be off-key it would really it's
so hard to imagine seeing your
opportunity well it is it is oh plea
you're not that you're not pavarotti
we're like no i'm not but i have i have
a good ear so i know when i'm a little
off-key singing and it's when you have a
good ear it's difficult to sing off-keys
it's difficult to do it on purpose
oh yeah so it's hard to imagine both
would be annoying for people but well
but but the uh the talking would you
sing it quietly here's the problem
the reason i would pick the singing is
because
uh
you would be like annoying and people
would think you're weird but the talking
if you're commenting on stuff that's
going around you on around you you would
be
potentially very insulting to other
people oh right so i wouldn't want to
take that chance if i'm being honest
well
she's not saying i read that correctly
she's not oh if you're if you're a
common commentary maybe yeah commenting
on like can you believe this
is i gotta stay here and listen to this
that's what i'm picturing and i wouldn't
want to do that yeah like um because
then you're gonna really alienate well
because most of the people i talk to
that i just encounter like let's say at
the supermarket or in the neighborhood
it's like
there are some pretty
snarky things i could say you know or
like i wouldn't i god forbid that comes
out of my mouth in front of them if the
hypothetical is either sing everything
like you're a musical off-key off pitch
or
just uh talk to the quote-unquote camera
about tom brady i think i'd rather do
that yeah if i have to talk about the
people around me i wouldn't she says
narrate to the camera talking about
people who are currently around you like
they're not there couldn't do that
yeah also like you could sing things
like this like
right now we're recording a podcast
and it's i don't have to be loud but i'm
still technically singing
and what are you doing afterwards but
that sounds too good i think in this
hypothetical would have to be how do you
know if it's off-key if it's not like a
song like a like established song like
maybe that's the key i'm singing in
and i'm going thinking about maybe going
to the grocery store is there a special
on any sort of fish is that the end of
the letter oh no
sorry
as much as i'm enjoying that
thank you for um
yeah it is thanks for being you alyssa
and casey that's really nice alyssa and
casey they listen to casey didn't write
it i know but casey enjoys the show yeah
thanks casey
um yeah they're genslinger fans what do
you think of when you hear casey what's
the first name yeah whoo anthony i just
thought of but
casey at the bat uh casing the sunshine
band casey
you know what the first thing that came
to mind
let me see if i can guess the first
thing casey casey
what casey and jojo
oh and then the second thing was casey
kasem oh casey kasem here oh really yeah
casey and joshua yeah of course not of
course it's not exactly uh a hip current
reference of course
casey and jojo
well regardless thank you casey thanks
yeah and alyssa alyssa and casey
and thank you to john hodgman
the brilliant
hysterical that was yeah one of the
funniest episodes we've had i would say
really yeah that's right up there that's
well now right up there with the alec
baldwin episode for me wow yeah you said
it and max greenfield that was super
funny too wow uh
and i well he's such a great
so see what see what i mean we were
talking about a hell of a brain he's
such a [ __ ] rich beautiful oh he also
has a podcast that we should um yes
judge to judge judge john hodgman and
it's
uh it's on
every oh he's referenced it so many
times we there's a lot of episodes it
doesn't matter when they come out yeah
yeah john's gotta in fact i think he
might have two podcasts and he's got a
new book coming out that is so funny um
it is medallion status and it's it's
gonna be in paperback it is in paperback
right now it's out right now medallion
status uh check it out follow him on
instagram he's very funny and if you
guys want to write into the show our
email address is life is short onery.com
and we will talk to you next week yes oh
happy halloween happy halloween right
it's coming up uh sure is oh boy what
are you going as
um i'm going as a sriracha bottle
oh yeah i'm so jealous of that costume
because it's convenient too it's right
it's perfect you got a green christmas
got a green hat with a little green tip
with a sriracha a sriracha bottle shirt
it's great ah you're so lucky uh we got
these nice sweatshirts you can get the
same costume we could both be sriracha
bottles you don't pull those
that'd be funny no i think i you know i
had an idea i turned it into a cartoon
um did you see my cartoon about the uh
the kid who was that's funny not wearing
a mask so a bunch of kids are like
trick-or-treating and a guy's at the
door about to give them candy and one of
them is not wearing a mask or any
discernible discernible costume
and uh the kid just says well i am
wearing them
i am wearing a cops no no not having a
mask is my costume more effective you
just look at the cartoon yeah i know but
i'm not bragging about it not
this is old-fashioned comedy the kids
are like oh is this what you meant by
old-fashioned comedy called comedies
yeah dad jokes but he says uh
uh not having a mask is my costume i'm a
selfish super spreader
all right all right i'll just put it on
instagram once it doesn't get into the
new yorker happy halloween
do that and if you're going to do
anything
it's just a graveyard smash
i hope all of you have a smashing
halloween
is that a good monster mash voice that's
brilliant
[Music]
life is short has been hosted by me
justin long it's co-hosted and produced
by you
christian
as well as megan monaco senior producer
is michelle it's creepy meech
audio engineers sergio enriquez with our
executive producers the ever diabolical
marshall louie and hernan lopez
wondering
look out for ghouls
wait what do you want him to go
so what is that
it's really nice i it sounds sounds more
embarrassing than a facial i can't
believe there's something i need more
information then it's really
it's nice minutes
oops okay
so far you're not any closer to finding
out it's using a cellular refining
screen it's 190 it eliminates unlocked
skin cells and nourishes your skin with
specially harvested rose oil
skin is visibly smoother you just don't
want to be able to say that you've had
rose oil i don't think i can do that why
um
because i feel like any shred of
masculinity i have now
would be gone if i got something like
that wait will you describe the rose
water thing again margaret okay
it's
specially harvested rose oils
so it's basically omega 3 6 and 9.
your skin is
smoother
my skin is so smooth already
the penetration of serums and
moisturizers
i don't use that stuff
margaret margaret that that this would
be a big waste of money and time
i don't i don't i don't think i need
that i'm not like some hairy like city
guy
i'm like i'm smooth i'm clean
i know but i don't know a body buff i
need to exfoliate all my skin
never i've never body buffed
you